bravo vai domanda la7
è da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti ha visto
marco 2 ha sbagliato fini che ancora una
volta uguale dopo facciamogli a
compilation dei fake e da tutti ragazzi
e benvenuti questo video sono falli j
e oggi siamo con nichi box e al gruppo
astana euro
vabbè dai non è un nome brutto e di
versante diverse l'angolo di serie my
friends del the shell gaming michiara un
tipo tre anni che non facciamo una
partita così dimostrare assieme c'è la
bandiera del burundi dove si prende
fermi la voglio anch'io poi nel garage
nelle bandiere o ruggi burundi ecco
tutti i pianali rosso anziché viola sono
tutti e tre professionisti gli altri
targati a partite che si metteranno lo
cava estivo non ho neanche mai visto
vetera bravo io ci vado io sono in mezzo
potete 2 m scusa
[Musica]
bravo vai riguarda la sexy
qualcuno se lo stesse chiedendo non
siamo mai stati troppo a posto noi tre
però vale centraggio sapete cosa la
vinciamo anche sua partita brescia e
provincia
no ragazzi no no no togliermi chi no
no non è così oddio tu farai che gol ma
non è che gori di chi box che nei secoli
fatto segnare così vai da tanto che non
è che nome della madonna chance era
appunto io la vedo io no vai vai in
mezzo ma è lui calma ragazze perdiamo
veramente viene infatti guarda guarda
vanta la guarda la guarda lì ci sono
bellavista by luca vai luca attenzione
ripartendo da gol bravo sì sì sì no no
kids mainichi mainichi mani
l'ha fatto connessione che da un mese
dalla salda luca che già è già qualcosa
mi chiese riusciti a vincere contro dai
2 ai supplementari tra valore che si
chiama quando a fare una roba tipo di a
nichi contro luca il che sarà
impossibile vincere e perdere ma trovano
i blu ray o ci sei mi chi li facciamo il
culo
by faber è ovvio lori del primo gol
subito così o no ma cosa non è possibile
facciamo una cosa che lo picchio dove
serio sono qui che faccio lo slalom
attenzione e non è possibile grande
vichi e tu a pensare che cosa no il 2
non l'abbiamo presa tutti i segnali
sopra gli son passato sotto non un
creativo picchiare allora sono in fa
quel suono rivedere tom e jerry e
imprenditori sta facendo gol ci ha
segnato volta che l'hai tolta tu che hai
cazzo rischi non segneranno segnalano
segnarsi nella fila diffidati vista no
non è possibile
bravo vai col
666 per cattiveria la prepotenza nelle
mie remore vinti mondiali re che devo
distrarre luca quando dico calcestruzzo
distraendo si recupera si recupera tutto
i nonni minimi fate incazzato ma i files
in porta ma dove vado io
sotto il braccio ma dollaro visto
piangere qualcuno adesso sempre di
qualcuno già lì fuori dal finestrino
total vengono spesso io no mi ha
sbattuto tra l'altro sono ancora dato
l'ampio mezzo anche tu a madonna che
anni che ha attivato chi che lei fa
attraverso da 0 a 3 a 4 3 l'ingaggio che
le più veloci di né madonna madonna che
gol a baku 99 per fugare madonna ora che
colti a fattori di afa giochiamo in due
grazie
ho preso la traversa
no perché insegnano no avrei segnato
qui sono in fosse entrata io pensavo non
boruc ha tanti meriti non pestare un
festeggiamento
magari sarà mica finito non so io
importa se vai vai pensione il gol
allora no non andava presa guarda ai
lori no che cosa l'ho fatto io lo vedo è
stato bello mi chiami può morire ma la
marcia dobbiamo già facciamo bastare
sì sì stiamo fai j
faccio il dj no no no ciao bella ciao
champion 2 1 in rimonta
dobbiamo vincerla questa è che si lavori
per forza dai signori senza volta di una
palla completamente tipo non c'è più la
palla ai tory mancanello che gol
ci hai è entrato chi cazzo ma perché 61
online ha causato in due la vinciamo
comunque blake raison vuol dire rasoio
qualcosa no non solo da lei in
territorio da lei ce la possiamo fare
gol fino a valori ma donna a donna che
assist hai fatto bellissimo il
grandissimo è che ho pagato allora che
assist fantastico siamo 4 2 e maicon
ormai vinciamo noi abbiamo vinto noi
il che è incredibile e l'esito ha
parlato i piccoli sa molto di più vai
vai viaggiava molto più veloce madonna
che bordello rimbalza troppo c'è un folk
aperta quella lingua anche se gli lori
adesso voglio [ __ ] sotto casa con
chi o se non è un problema ma come mamma
mia che ho visto è questo è topico come
ti ho visto guarda come tralasciata il
velo grande banca profession
[Musica]
no togliere di chi no nichi i dati
fidati la prenderà mai ma voglio ma non
posso non lo fate con noi ma domani in
gara ma lo schifo mare che si segna pure
mi chiedo però è compreso che culo è
nitido queste parti cosa fai gli chiede
cosa fai mickey cosa fai
luca è rimasto disorientato davvero no
non mancate a nicchie 21 bravo voglio
fare che seguire la nostra parte credo
lo rifaccio dai come hai tolta grande
che lo piccolo piccolo no non sono
riuscito a segnare lo stesso ma con un
po bravo luca ha segnato lui 40 a luca
offre da bere che offre da bere ai club
che suoli e stato figo il problema è che
va bene luca offrirà da bene il pari
vero abito abbia vinto noi non ti
preoccupare lauryl stato lo sporco
esatto che sia ragazzi e concludo più
episodio ce ne saranno sicuramente altri
gli episodi così perché minchia na
figata
a me piace a me personalmente è piaciuto
un sacco cioè mi diverto i temi del
perché dobbiate comando aiuto ed i
ragazzi servire piaciuto se i 300 vento
mi piace che piace di facebook e di
votare nell'edizione che sono stati
studiati amici vi diamo prossimo video
della bella da ragazzi